So I'm Matthieu Ricard, a Buddhist monk, I
live since 40 years in the Himalayas and the
French interpreter for the Dalai-Lama. So
I'm here in Davos, which is quite surprising
for a Buddhist monk. What I think w can contribute
is to realize what Gandhi said is there is
enough for everyone's need but there is not
enough for everyone's greed. And I think one
lesson that the present crisis can teach us
is that just the pursuit of self's happiness
is about to fail. Especially when it's corrupted
with greed. And the lesson that we can take
from this crisis is that we need to work forward
toward the more altruistic side. More altruistic
like dealing with people's investments. Not
like what we are doing with the casino. Be
more concerned and altruistic against peole
flourishing in life. The way the work, the
environment. And more altruistic for future
generations and what they can care of the
environment. So it seems that altruism or
a more altruistic society is the single answer
to all those three kinds of care. And that
is not sort of an interpret view or idealist
view, but is really in tune to the independence
of the world. So if we can understand the
proposition of interdependence and seek a
win win situation of exploiting orders, I
think people will have taken serious lessons
from this economic crisis.